Without further ado, Danny Seo!
(audience cheering)
Hi!
Wow, Drew.
None of that was in the prompter.
Thank you.
None of that was
in the prompter and I speak the truth.
All right, what are we doing first?
Well, I know you love makeup.
So we are gonna talk
I wear a lot of it.
about makeup brushes, guys.
So if you are not cleaning your makeup brushes,
you're basically just reapplying germs and bacteria
right onto your skin.
But also we wanna be environmentally friendly
and not just constantly replace them.
So we're gonna show you how to wash them.
It's so simple.
You start with olive oil
because you wanna make sure the bristles stay nice and soft.
If you just wash it with soap and water,
it gets really hard.
So we're gonna take the dish soap,
pour it into the olive oil.
This is gonna do all of your brushes right here.
And we're emulsification process.
Emulsified, this is not a salad dressing.
(everybody laughing)
It looks like a yummy vinegarette, but it's not.
It does.
You take your brush, this is super dirty.
We're gonna put it in here, swirl it around
just a little bit.
So we're gonna take our beaker,
take our brush and watch the magic happen,
ready?
Is this water?
Yeah, and you just put in water in your sink or whatever
and then you swirl it
and look how much comes out of that brush.
(audience applauding)
Look at this. Look at this.
I love you.
(audience laughing)
Cheers, Drew.
(everybody laughing)
(audience applauding)
No.
Oh my God.
ugh, and it does, it's like mink, it feels so good.
Okay, wow, next.
Okay.
Now let's talk about carpets, okay?
So I feel like carpets are making a huge comeback in homes.
Don't you feel like?
I love a cozy carpet
and when you have kids and pets-
It can smell.
Whoa.
Right?
If you don't want like a machine,
if you don't wanna go through the hassle,
what I like to do is I take a little sieve
just like this and two simple ingredients.
So if you've got baking soda and cinnamon, cinnamon, okay?
So these are two things that are great deodorizers
for your carpet.
So I will fill up even a bigger one at home.
I'll take baking soda, fill it up right into my container
and then I'll add a big tablespoon of cinnamon right here
and these are two deodorizers.
These are two things that go deep into the carpet.
You let it sit for 24 hours.
What it's doing, it's pulling the excess moisture.
It's killing all the germs of bacteria.
It's freshening with natural cinnamon.
(Drew gasps)
And then.
(everybody laughing)
All right.
You've got a blizzard over there.
(everybody laughing)
Well, I-
It's clean.
Oh my God, it's.
(audience laughing)
It's totally clean.
I know,
you know me, Danny, I am just OTT, over the top.
(everybody laughing)
(audience applauding)
Good news, I made a tiramisu.
That you did.
You let it sit for 24 hours
and then you just vacuum it all up with a vacuum.
Just make sure it doesn't get wet.
Don't let anyone, they're trampling in there,
like keep a pet away for sure.
And then you got a fresh carpet.
I love that.
I love it so much because I'm always talking
about in our Stans for stain segments,
please don't push it down.
It's all about the art
of lifting.
Lifting.
(audience applauding)
(Danny laughs)
Okay, Danny, next!
Keep it all lifted.
And then I know this is something you're obsessed with,
are stains, like on clothes and things.
This is my, why buy it when you can DIY it?
That's what I call it.
You can make your own stain remover.
It's got a little bit of that same soap,
I use a Castile soap
or a dish soap, whatever you want, baking soda,
that same ingredient we just had, hydrogen peroxide.
And it all goes into a dark container
because these are all very active ingredients.
And then this is soy sauce
right here on a sweater.
So for me, this is
very likely to be a stain on my clothing.
And we're just gonna spray away and be generous with this.
And this is something where dish soap cuts grease,
baking soda is a natural cleaning agent,
hydrogen peroxide bubbles, and lifts everything up.
Lift it! Don't push on it.
(Danny laughs)
Which is the magic.
And by the way, you can find these online.
These are little, if you want a to go version,
you just fill this little to go pen, it's refillable.
What?
Rub it in.
(audience laughing)
You know, if you have like a little stain right here.
Where did you find that?
Online. You can find these anywhere online.
These are fantastic.
Go to thedrewbarrymoreshow.com.
We'll tell you where to get them.
(audience laughing)
And I'll be ordering one
right alongside of you.
It comes right out.
It's like, it really, this really does work.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)